i can't think of anything that it would
feel better to be completely wrong about
than criminal charges and donald trump
the news is that donald trump's lawyers
now seem increasingly convinced this
guy's getting charged criminally and
they are now preemptively planning how
to handle criminal charges against the
former president donald trump now until
it happens it's nothing okay and it
hasn't happened yet
i've been saying all along
trump's not getting charged
and i would love to be wrong i won't eat
my microphone i need the microphone for
the show
but i would love to be wrong about it
very interesting new article from
rolling stone
trump's lawyers are preparing legal
defenses against criminal charges
according to internal communications
reviewed by rolling stone trump's team
is quietly planning for criminal charges
as they wait for the justice department
to make its move this would be
absolutely historic it would be an
historic day in fact
donald trump's lawyers are preemptively
preparing a legal defense agreements
criminal charges from the justice
department
as the former president's lawyers are
increasingly anxious their client will
be prosecuted for his role in the
attempt to overturn the 2020 election
members of trump's legal team have
already started to brainstorm strategy
and potential defenses according to
three people familiar with the matter
and written communications reviewed by
rolling stone understand that rolling
stone has reviewed written
communications presumably emails and or
text messages
where it is being discussed by trump's
lawyers
how they would handle such criminal
charges trump himself has been briefed
on potential legal defenses on at least
two occasions this summer that effort
intensified after trump white house
former trump white house aide cassidy
hutchinson's june testimony before the
house committee investigating january
6th
quote members of the trump legal team
are quietly preparing in the event
charges are brought it would be career
career malpractice not to do so do the
former president attorneys believe
everything cassidy said no
do they think the department of justice
would be wise to charge him no
but we've gotten to a point where if you
don't think criminal charges are at
least somewhat likely you are not
serving the former president's best
interests
folks i know i've been saying all along
trump's not getting charged
i hope i'm wrong i will come and throw
my with tears in my eyes i will come to
all of you and say
sirs and mams i was wrong and i love it
now
what is a preview of trump's legal
defense is it going to be made up
significantly of presidential immunity
that's it
we don't know but it is certainly
plausible that trump will try the
immunity defense legal experts think
it's unlikely the supreme court would
allow that
another possibility would be
some version of what's sometimes
referred to as the oliver north defense
the idea there is you really can't try
trump for any of this stuff
because you can't actually get a jury
because everyone witnessed the crime the
the the things that he is potentially
going to be charged with if he's charged
we're operating in a world where he gets
charged the things he would be charged
with are things that
he did at least partially in public so
how do you get a jury
that will really be able to restrict its
judgment
to just what is presented during a trial
now i've actually talked about another
problem when it comes to such charges
how do you even find a jury aside from
people that saw the alleged crimes in
public
how do you find a jury
with no preconceived opinion based on
their beliefs about trump and what i
mean by that is
with some crimes if the crime takes
place in kansas city
missouri
you say well let's move it to the next
county over where people aren't familiar
with the crime
but this is a national really a global
situation that relates to trump's
attempt to steal the election
and also
most people have a very strong opinion
of trump i mean listen
i if i were to be called to be on this
jury
i can't imagine they would want me on
there since i've been doing years of
commentary about exactly what the trial
would be about but i'll be totally
upfront with you at this point i don't
think it would be possible for me to put
aside my opinions about trump and the
case
and say only based on what's in maybe in
the trial they don't have the clip of
trump asking for 11
780 votes am i really going to be able
to pretend that that didn't happen i
need 11 000 votes give me a break i
don't know so so another question is how
do you actually get a get a jury let's
wait and see but the fact that trump's
lawyers are now preparing for criminal
charges
certainly suggestive of the fact that
they are more likely than at any
previous point to be coming as many of
you know i'm a busy person i don't
always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time-consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever or
spend time planning when what time of
day do i need to take each one i just
get it all with one scoop you can put it
in a smoothie you can drink it straight
it tastes great and then i'm just good
for the day it supports gut health and
i'm getting everything that i need and
i'm looking for athletic greens is
giving my audience a free one-year
supply of vitamin d plus five free
travel packs when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below